[Music]
[Applause]
well awesome I'm happy to be here thank
you for coming to my talk I did not plan
the talk before me so if you were here
before and it's all to talk about Cyprus
we're gonna be talking about testing and
we're gonna be talking about not end to
end but we are going to be talking and
we are going to be testing a to do NBC
app so in Cyprus will be mentioned in
this talk so that was kind of a perfect
setup so my talk is about testing big
and with big tests and hello everyone
I'm Robert De Luca you can find me at
Rob Dell 12 on the internet anywhere
basically github Twitter anything on the
internet I work for a consultancy called
the front side we build software that
you can secure your future on we do
basically UI and JavaScript consulting
and at the front side we care deeply
about testing and specifically is unit
tests or integration tests I ran across
this tweet that I know Kent C Dodds
really likes and I also really like it
write tests not too many
mostly integration and I agree with this
so much and so much so in some of our
applications we probably have about five
or six unit tests and the rest ring in
our integration tests and I'll show you
at the end of this talk about how how we
get there so to kind of get on the same
page I want to talk about UI tests what
are you eye tests so yeah let's make
sure we get on the same page about it
I'm talking about rendering the full
application in the browser not just a
single component the whole enchilada
and I want to rerender a fresh
application for each assertion I don't
want any leftover State from the
previous test run I want to make sure
that I can put the application
repeatedly into the same exact state
each time I want to test the application
like it's used a user isn't going to be
unit testing your app they're not going
to be looking up a function that's
passed
click Handler and calling that directly
they're gonna be clicking there to be
typing they're gonna be scrolling I want
to mock my network requests this is the
big difference between a dentists and UI
tests and an dentist can be slow and it
requires some work to set up and
sanitizer data to make sure that you
don't have any leftover data that's
control you and future tests which is
not fun so what are the benefits of UI
testing
well they test the integration of all
the components together I want to make
sure that my application works together
as a whole not individually in pieces
like I talked about earlier I want to
test like a user I want to be clicking I
want to be scrolling I want to be
dragging and dropping I want to be doing
all the things that I do while I
interact with my app and I want to test
that way and test test the loop between
the browser and application I want to
make sure when the browser sends an
event my application can handle that
properly we all know cross browser bugs
exists and sometimes an event that's
sent has different properties than other
browsers or something quirky will go on
even though there's a spec there's still
bugs I want to test on many different
browsers and platforms my my users
aren't going to be just using Chrome
they're not going to be just using
Firefox and they definitely are not
using jsm I want to test an IE edge
Firefox iOS Chrome or iOS Safari Android
Chrome I want to test on all of those so
that's great but what are the trade-offs
here UI tests can be hard to set up a
lot of times you can end up in
configuration hell and I think some of
us have probably been there before
they're typically hard to maintain I've
been on - I've worked the two companies
that have entire teams dedicated to
writing these Suites and maintaining
them they can be slow we've all seen
sleep 10 or you know when they somebody
commits something and it broke a test or
it broke a test and they just increment
the sleep I don't want that you can have
flaky tests false positives or false
negatives the elements are not existing
but
that that's something that we don't want
in our tests so what what frameworks can
do this UI testing all of these they can
do UI testing I'm gonna mention a lot of
these I can do and n testing but you can
mock the network as you wish
so with whatever method you want so the
first one everybody's probably heard of
is selenium or at least I worked with or
at least heard of the new kid on the
block which we just heard about which
was Cypress and then protractor which is
pretty popular with angular apps just
and puppeteer which is interesting set
up I've seen a couple articles pop up
about this but as a whole UI testing
hasn't changed very much so this is what
some tests with like in selenium you're
gonna get the browser you're gonna set
up the driver or you get a drive it
around with Cypress everything's
prefixed through the side command and so
I thought get side I contains those
things I got paws protractor is a little
bit more towards the modern scale like a
modern scale however you want to
classify that it has some page object II
like things like it number but you still
see in there like browser dot get title
browser go here and then just then
puppeteer which I I don't think you can
see it up there in the slides but
there's two sleeps in there that are 1.6
million milliseconds which is about a
half hour that's that's pretty high so
it's just a lot of directing the browser
to do things browser do this browser do
that wait for this element but the way
we've built UI has changed in a really
big way and the way we have tested
typically hasn't and we can thank
libraries like this backbone view and
Euler ember react and like a hundred
thousand other JavaScript libraries that
are out there I learned today that dojo
has made a big comeback so we could
throw that in there and the changes that
they've brought are faster rendering
components everywhere in a very
componentized world everything can be
broken down into digestible and
shareable and composable components
there's a lot more asynchrony we're
doing a lot more get requests and a lot
more
Ajax and generally just became more
interactive and basically the too long
didn't read it is their more
feature-rich we've been racing towards
becoming as feature-rich as native apps
and with that there's been massive
booming boom and tooling to become more
feature-rich and and handle all of the
problems that come along with being more
feature-rich in our ecosystem so tools
like babel web pack yes land parcel type
scripts all the things that we all
probably use or use one of these tools
daily has really changed the way that
we've developed java scripts in the past
10 years but UI testing tools haven't
necessarily moved or evolved with the
the front-end tooling world and that's
that's a pretty bold claim right so what
are we looking for what's missing then
well I want my test framework to be it
will be built with components in mind I
want composability in my tests that are
similar to composability and our
components
I want reliable Dom interactions I don't
want anything flaky of course I don't
want false positives or false negatives
I want chainable interactions when I'm
running a test that's filling in a form
I want to be able to fill in a couple
inputs chain one off one after another
and then click Submit and of course we
all want speed that's just a given I
feel like I probably didn't even need to
put that in my slides but we all want
speed and I want to take advantage of
our modern tooling things like
typescript anything like that and when
I'm thinking about this specifically
things like stripping data attributes
out of your your application for a
production build so when you're testing
you're not using brittle CSS selectors
that are also testing or that are also
providing style right like if I have a
button that is read with the class name
read and I wrote a test that selects
from that and I change the color and the
behavior didn't change my test shouldn't
fail I want maintainability and
scalability UI tests tend to become very
fragile a lot of the time there are
those dedicated teams that are writing
those tests and not developed by
the team that's actually developing the
code and that's not something that we
like to do with the front side we think
that the developers should be writing
the tests alongside of implementing the
features because they know the features
I want full control over the network I
want to be able to create data as I need
to put the application in the weirdest
States at that that the user finds
themselves in I want to be able to slow
timings down increase or make the
timings faster to test different loading
States I want it to be cross framework
we're consultants so we want something
that we can take on any client project
so that means it needs to work and react
or view or basically anywhere there's
Dom or JavaScript and we're consultants
and we want it to work across test
frameworks too because we're typically
not able to be there in a greenfield
project to make that decision or help
them make that decision there's a little
asterisk there on just because I am
talking about UI testing in the browser
and technically just can't run on the
browser but you you can tack it I wanted
to be cross browser
this is a hard requirement we must be
able to test in many different browsers
and in today's day and age a lot of our
users are using mobile so I want to be
able to I must be able to test and
mobile our users aren't going to be
using JSON like I said and none of these
frame current frameworks out there kind
of meet these criteria for us each one
check a few of the boxes Cypress is
absolutely the closest but as far as I
can tell her I know it only works in
Chrome and Firefox is hot on its heels
but it also doesn't really take
components into consideration so we set
out and built the thing that we wanted
and the name of that is big tests it's
called big tests because we're testing
Bigley right unit tests are small and UI
tests are big big tests can work
anywhere there's Dom or JavaScript we
use a server to run the tests so if your
browser can visit a URL it can run the
tests I wanted to be cross framework
it's so or it is cross framework so it
is written and plain JavaScript it can
be used and adapted in any any frame
to use and is cross test framework bring
your favorite test framework or a runner
and we tend to like mocha so that's
that's what we're gonna be using in the
future examples give you we give you
full control over the network so you can
create data as you wish you can slow
those timings down you can throw 500
errors to test that your client side you
error handling is working you can do
whatever you wish and it's built with
components in mind components are at the
center of big tests we ship these things
called interactors with our component
framework and the consuming app can
import those interactors and use them
directly because the the component
framework is already testing its
components rights so i don't need to
write tests specifically around
interacting with that component i can
just import it and use what they wrote
so someone once told me if you have a
complicated problem such as UI testing
give a simple example don't use a
complicated example with a complicated
testing so UI testing got me in my
feelings
everybody likes some Drake so I'm going
to use to do MVC as a simple example and
I'm gonna do it a little bit harder I'm
going to a big test to two MVC with an
API so this is a gift example of what
these tests might look like when running
so what are our goals here what do we
want to accomplish by the end of this
talk
well I want to set up big test in an
existing project I want to introduce and
build a component interactors together
I want to mock the network layer and
let's write some big tests so we have a
to do MVC starter app and what's the
structure there it's kind of just a
typical react up there we have a source
folder with components inside of it we
have a models folder for handling state
in this application and then we have an
index and some some styles and stuff so
it's just basically a typical react
project you might run across we use
parcel to build because parcel is
awesome you can use webpack or whatever
you want but in this example we're using
parcel if people
familiar with what to do MVC is this is
how the app works right you can create
some - dues you can filter them and you
can complete them so let's get big test
set up this has no test it's just a
fresh project so we need to install some
dependencies we're going to install the
big test CLI the big test interactors
are a wrapper around mocha which is not
necessarily needed but if you use mocha
and you want to write in that style go
ahead and use it and then we're going to
include the big test react helper we're
going to use MPX to run the init command
which is going to create all the files
that we need if you haven't used MPX
it's pretty rad should use it so when we
run big tests in it it's going to create
this folder structure in your project so
we have the big test folder and then we
have our helpers folder inside of that
which one helper and then we have our
interactors folder which is where all
interactions happen where our
application and all of our tests so
that's the test that are actually
running and it also creates an index
file and a big test options file so we
need to tell big test launcher how to
serve our application big test works by
bundling all your tests together
alongside your application so we need to
change your bundlers entry point to the
big test folder with parcel that's
pretty easy because it's parcel right so
we're going to create an index.html file
because that's what they recommend to
serve from an HTML and we're gonna point
the entry of that that of the parcel
want alert to our big test file that we
just created so if we look at our npm or
package JSON file and our scripts we've
created a new script that is start :
tests and points to the big test
index.html this is gonna bundle all our
things together if you're using webpack
you can or whatever you want you can do
it in this style the runner and CLI when
you run it automatically sets the node M
to test so you can just change when
you're in test mode to change the entry
from just the normal entry to the big
tests entry file so the next thing we
need to do is set up big test run which
actually runs the tests we're going to
go back into our scripts file we're
going to add a new test command here
five which just does big test run which
is good to call it directly from the
binary that's installed on our project
from the dependencies and then we're
gonna edit our big test
ops file we have to tell the launcher
how to do three things for us the first
thing is how to serve that app and we're
going to point it to the command that we
just created if you're using webpack
like you showed earlier you don't even
have to you can just pass yarn tests or
yarn start just like you would normally
start your application the next one
we're gonna do is we're gonna tell the
application where to actually serve to
and in our case it's going to be
localhost one-two-three-four because
that's a default port number for parcel
which i think is awesome and lastly
you're gonna tell big test what adaptor
and what framework test framework you're
using I'm like I said you can use any
one that you want so we're gonna pass
mocha here and currently we only have
support for mocha but as I talk right
now one of my co-workers is building
other adapters so let's take a look at
these test files they're just it's just
a fresh sweet these are our mocha tests
and in this test on line 15 we are
asserting that the title of the
application equals to do and it has an
h1 and this is what an interact or looks
like we have a class that has a property
on it called title title text and we're
gonna grab the text from the h1 element
on the page now we're going to learn a
lot more about interactors in a little
bit so let's finish setting up last
thing we need to do is set up the setup
app helper this is this is the thing
that actually renders your application
into the browser and this is what that
that that file looks like we're going to
import our route app for a route
component and pass it to set up a for
testing the helper that we provide for
from big tests react this is typically
whatever you pass to react Dom but in
some cases and applications that we've
seen you might wrap it around with the
test harness component that provides
some other things and like fake loggers
and in redux or whatever you might want
big tests react also provides other
things like you can pass props to it
initial props or whatever you want and
you can also if you're using react
router it'll automatically hook in a
reactor outer for you so you can use the
at command to visit relics in your tests
so let's run some tests and we have a
single passing test
so let's there's a good place to take a
break and review where we're at we have
successfully set up big tests and
existing project the next thing we're
gonna do is build some component
interactors together so I think this is
a good spot to pause and and talk about
interactors and what they are
interactors allow you to think about how
to interact with your component and your
application as a whole click this drag
this scroll here focus this they will
wait for elements to exist before
interacting with them so you don't have
to worry about timing or or getting to
sync up with a run loop or anything
it'll just work for you I don't have
enough time to get into how it all
actually works in the architecture
underneath that's a whole talk in itself
but just know that it takes care of that
for you interactors our core two big
tests they're the heart and soul of a
big test and I think arguably probably
the coolest feature and even though
we're saying the big test is a testing
framework you could take interactors and
plug it into Cypress if you want or
whatever testing framework that you want
because these are just a collection of
modules so you don't have to wait for
the ability to interact and interactors
abstract that away for you so you don't
have to worry about that timing or
anything it'll do it interact or
properties are lazy so they don't
actually run until you try to access the
getter on it
they're composable and they are
chainable and I think very powerful so
if you want to go check out the API dots
and go to big tests JSI o slash guides
to interactors and we have three or four
guides there for you about creating
custom interactors composing them with
other interactors if you want to go and
learn at your own pace or take a look at
the all the API Doc's that we have so
let's start filling in our interactor we
to give like a simplest view of what we
were doing here is where we have set up
our application where we've rendered it
into the browser and now we're gonna
start driving the application around
with interactors so this begs a question
of how do we actually even interact with
our application and even for something
that's as simple as to do MVC there's a
lot that's going on here there's a lot
of different ways you can interact with
your application so let's stop and break
this down and just tackle adding it to
do first let's look back at the slim
diagram here just for adding it to do
you have input here where you type it in
the input and then you press ENTER to
submit you can also toggle a button on
the left to complete all to Do's so
we're at the top here we're already
asserting that we have our two dues or
two dues title there so that's done for
us now we just need to wire up our
interactor for actually submitting or
actually entering data into the input
and then submitting that that to do so
our actor is grown a little bit here I
want to call out line 12 we have a new
to do property which is equal to a
fillable method that we provide from
interactor and what fillable is going to
do is allow you to fill an input with
whatever data you want in your test and
then here on lines 15 to 17 we have a
submit to do property that we have equal
to a trigger Abul method that's provided
from interactor also which allows us to
trigger whatever event that we want in
this case we're going to trigger a
keydown event and send the key code 13
which is the enter key on the new to do
input field so that's that's great I
guess
so let's route this in reality and see
how we actually use this in a test so
same from earlier test suite that we
have right but we have a new describe
block and I want to kind of walk through
how interactors are playing a role here
first we're going to import the
interactor from the folder and at the
very top of the file we're going to
instantiate our enter actor and then
down here on lines 22 23 we're gonna
actually start interacting with our app
we named our to do to the or interact or
to do app so when we call that
interactor we're gonna do to do app dot
new to do and then
we passed two is actually going to be
the value of that's entered into the
input fields and then we just chain on a
submit to do interactor and bam we're
going to submit so we actually don't
have anything to assert against right
now all right if we look back at the
tests here you can see the assertion
down at the bottom is just a comment
that says oh so let's take a look back
at our diagram here and look at a to-do
item so we have our adding it to do
interactor kind of all fleshed out so in
order for us to assert we have an
infinite number of to-do items in this
list and when we built this application
we recognized that we could pull that
out onto a component right we could
build something and it's called to do I
don't so naturally with each component
there can be an interact or that maps
directly to and how you interact with
that component so we're going to try and
we're going to match that composability
that we get from the component with our
tests so let's create a new interactor
called to-do item and we're gonna create
one property for now on it called to do
text and that's just going to grab text
from the label element on the to-do item
and then we're to compose or to do item
interactor with our to-do MVC interactor
the same way that we compose the to-do
item component in the two MVC
application when we built it so we're
going to go back to the to-do MVC
interactor and add a new property on
line 16 called to-do list and it's going
to be set to a collection and
collections from interactor are just a
way for you to scope your nested
interactors to a specific selector so if
we go back here you remember how I'm
just pulling off text from a label which
is pretty vague right we can do that
because we have we have it scoped with a
collection and it's only going to look
for the label inside of to-do list Li so
we don't have to worry about it trying
to grab some label that's way out of the
scope of the component now we can assert
that the to do was created right so
let's fill in that test since our to-do
list is a collection when we select from
what we're going to do
to do app dot to-do list and pass the
index of the item in the list that we
want to select so we want to select the
first one so we're going to pass the
zero index and then from there we can
just call the properties of the interact
on it so we're going to do to-do list
item zero the part the first item and
then get the text off of it and we're to
assert that equals my to do so let's run
the tests BAM there the other thing
about big test is is super fast or that
that ran on about three milliseconds I
think it says up there it's pretty best
so let's fill in the rest of our to-do
item interactor and and think about all
the ways that we can interact with just
a to-do item we can click the check box
to toggle the item so on line 13 there
we're setting a property called toggle
to a clickable element so it's going to
click that item when we call it we can
delete the item doing the same thing by
clicking we can check properties on
different elements and attributes also
but for this instance we're going to
check if the to do is completed by
checking the checked property on the
checkbox we're going to double click in
to and we're going to trigger a double
click event by to enter into edit mode
and then we're going to fill in that
edit input to edit it and then we can
press ENTER to submit that edit so let's
take a second there's a lot being thrown
at you and it's just positive check our
progress we've set a big test in an
existing project and we've kind of
introduced interactors and built some
together
so let's write some more tests for this
application right let's write test for
editing completing and deleting it to do
but we have a problem here
all these tests are end to end right now
and leftover data is causing issues and
we're still technically in this instance
of the application these are going
straight to production so that's not
good if you look at the gif here each
time i refresh the page here it's going
to make a network request and actually
submit it to do so by the time I'm done
refreshing here we have 6 to do's there
which isn't good if you're trying to
test the state in between each tests so
we're to use a thing called big test
Mirage
and what Mirage does is it creates a
client-side server that mimics your API
it has a fully featured database ORM and
allows you to have full control over the
data in your tests do you need 200
records the test pagination go for it
do you need zero records the check to
test an empty State awesome what about
throwing a 500 error from when
submitting at a forum and making sure
that your client side validation is
worked there great go for it it'll work
so I want to give a shout out to Sam
Celica for building Mirage if your an
ember developer you might be familiar
with that name
he built ember CLI Mirage and we just
pulled it out into a base JavaScript
library so everybody that uses
JavaScript can benefit from this awesome
library so we're to use big tests in it
and we're going to pass a network flag
here now so it can do all the
bootstrapping that we need because we
don't want to do all this work manually
and then we're going to add the big test
Mirage dependency as a dev dependency
and what that does is it creates this
this structure with some with some more
full subfolders here so alongside of our
helpers interactors and test file we
also have a network folder now that has
a bunch of other folders inside of it
but just you don't have to worry about
that right now just know it exists when
we run the big test in it with Network
it does update the setup app helper with
a few changes so let's take a look at
that the first thing that changes is
we're importing a start Mirage command
from the network folder and then we have
two new methods on the setup app for
testing helper here one is setup and one
is teardown so setup is called before
the application is actually rendered and
we're going to start the Mirage server
the client-side server we're gonna turn
logging off because that can be annoying
to see your test output but you can turn
that back on if you are debugging and
then after the test run we're going to
clean up after ourselves and shut down
the test server so what happens now that
we've run the big test in the command
with network and
I set up this and what happens when we
run our tests they're gonna fail and
something funny is going on here we're
gonna see a ton of errors here in our
console what's what's up with that
so Mirage intercepts all of your network
requests it's not gonna let any of them
out unless you actually let it or want
it so you can do a pass-through and or
actually talk to the real network but by
the default state it's not gonna let
anything talk to the network so let's go
ahead and mock our get endpoint so when
the application actually loads it's
gonna fetch all the to Do's
so let's mock that if we go into our big
test Network config folder or file we're
going to I'm gonna explain a couple
things here first thing you notice here
on line two is we're setting a URL
prefix which is a fully qualified URL
and this is a URL of our API this is
where an actual network request is going
out to and then here on line four since
we pass the URL the fully qualified URLs
or prefix we don't have to actually use
that in each endpoint that we're mocking
and we can just say that we're getting
on the route from that and when that
function is invoked you get a two
arguments to your function which is the
schema and the request that was actually
sent along with that network request and
in our case we're just going to return
some fixture data it's going to be an
array of one item that says my to do so
if we run the test again we get a little
bit further but it's still some errors
so let's mock the post endpoint and do
the same thing so we're gonna do the
exact same thing we're gonna pass the
same exact data back through and these
tests well pass right in this exact
configuration they will always pass no
matter what you do
since we're posting and getting the same
exact data type or the data style it
would always pass and fixtures just
don't get us very far
the second you need to test a different
state of your application it's gonna get
very complicated we managed fixtures and
an application about three years ago and
it was a nightmare to say the least so
let's just do some dynamic factories
factories allow us to create specific
data as we need throughout
our tests and have full control over the
data so if we look back at our folder
structure here we have two folders that
we're going to care about here it's a we
need to create a model and any factory
in the very near future probably like in
a week or two from now the CLI will take
care of this for us but conference
driven development isn't good enough for
for me here so we have to mean then we
water this up so we're gonna go into our
models folder and our index file and
we're going to uncomment and export the
file that we're about to create and then
we're going to go into our models
directory and create it to do model and
this is a place where you can create
relationships to other models and other
other data that you might have that your
application has or epi might have but
we're not doing anything special so
we're just gonna extend the model and
send it through we're gonna do the same
thing with factories and index and then
in our to do J's Factory we're gonna do
we're gonna create a factory that
matches the shape of our api's data I
want to call out something here for the
title you notice that we're using faker
which we import from Vic tests Mirage to
create something random so each time we
create a factory it's gonna create a
random title and at any given point if
you want you can override these by
passing a second argument to the create
command and you can create whatever
title you want whatever I do you want
whatever could state that you want you
have full control over that the last
thing that we need to do is we need to
uncomment imports and our big test
networks start file so we're gonna go in
and alliance 514 and set 16 and
uncomment those and make sure that those
those imports are being passed to the
Mirage constructor like I said in a very
very future that will be taken care of
for you but if you do this right now you
have to do it manually so now we can
manage dynamic data creation we don't
have to return fixtures from our API
mocks anymore right so with this updated
we are in our get we are destructuring
the to dues collection from the schema
that's passed to us and then since I get
we're just going to return to dues at
all I'll just return all of the to dues
that are in the database which is the
fake database right and then for our
host we're going to do the same thing in
destructuring out of the database
collection but we're also going to use
the request body from the request which
is what's sent along with your post
request and we're going to parse that
and then create a new to do based off of
that so it's all dynamic data for you
and then in the middle there we do some
updating of the record to make sure that
has the right property on it that our
API expects since we're using a MongoDB
here so Mirage has a concept of
scenarios where you can well create
scenarios from the data that you need
these can be really useful i we have an
application that uses all of this and
it's really nice when you're developing
new features I keep on giving the
client-side error handling example
because that's something that I actually
had to do I to make sure that I added
all of those improperly responded to the
API 500 errors so instead of actually
going through and trying to make the API
break I just created a Mirage scenario
and went to town on making sure that all
worked so we're going to create a
default scenario which is created by the
the CLI for you you can leave this blank
this will create this data for each test
run so be very sure this is what you
want to do if not you can create data
for your tests you need as you need when
you go to write those tests so in this
scenario we're just going to create four
to do's and it's just going to create
what's back and gave it so let's run the
test this year well that's that's a
weird error what's going on there oh
okay
so our response here from Mirage it has
a root object on it right as a to do key
and then inside of it an array of to
Do's and we're not expecting that we're
just expecting an array of objects so
let's we need to serialize our data to
match the shape that our API has that's
create a serialize err Mirage you can do
this for us so Mirage comes with three
serializers out-of-the-box for you you
can use a rest an active model or a JSON
API to réaliser you can also write your
own so you realize err if you really
want what we're just gonna use the basic
rest adapter here and
the same story here you have to make
sure the update your index file and I
make sure you import that to the Mirage
constructor so if we run the tests here
they're gonna pass and we have some fake
data in there so you can see that we
have a bunch of faker created records
there so congratulations we have
successfully mocked the network layer of
this really simple app that was a lot to
cover there I know but it's fully setup
with dynamic data that we can create
control whatever test scenario we please
like if we wanted to create 9002 dues we
can do that I don't recommend it though
it sounds like like a lot of anxiety so
now we can fill in the rest of our tests
things like editing toggling deleting
whatever you want to do with - dues so
nested interactors are pretty awesome
right so you can see they're on lines 4
to 7 we're doing some some nesting calls
to our to-do item interactor that we
created but writing to-do lists zero for
each interaction that we're gonna
perform is a little bit verbose and a
little bit annoying so let's let's not
do that and interactor provides us a way
to not have to do that we can just pass
and only after the chained interactor or
the Nessen interactor and now all the
interactions that we have under there
which is a double click filling the
input and then press enter will all
happen on the nested a nested interactor
there so let's skip the slide so this is
what our mocking endpoint looks like for
the edit which is a patch and deleting
which is a delete we're going to find
the parameter in our database collection
and then just pass it along and update
it with the attributes that are given in
the request and then similar story for
the delete we're gonna look up the
request ID and then actually just
destroy and then return the collection
that has the destroyed look so let's go
run our tests we have about 13 tests
here I didn't write a full-on test suite
but I could have
and I think those run pretty fast and so
you don't think I'm lying to you here is
big test running an iOS Safari Firefox
and Chrome also here so these are all
running our tests anywhere there's a
browser you could actually run this on a
physical device so like if you had my
network IP address and I started the
server you all could start running tests
just by visiting that URL so you can
find the full suite I can't fit it all
into a slide here at my github Rockdale
12 and big desk to do MVC so you can
check that out so we did it we set up
two MVC running big tests running in
cross browser and we learned how to what
interactor is we mocked our entire
network layers so we don't have to
actually talk to a real network and we
wrote some big tests so coming back to
complicated problems needs simple
examples I want to show a couple more
examples of what big test looks like in
interactors in a real production app
that we've been developing for one of
our clients so the first one would be
here where we're actually creating data
that we specifically need for this test
so we're testing that this thing called
a resource I'm not going to get into the
data model of this application because
it's really complicated but we're gonna
create a resource and create that it's
hidden and we're going to make some
assertions that in the UI that it
actually hides this thing from us and
then when we create that data we're
going to visit the URL of that data
that's created so on line 5 we set the
resource variable equal to the data that
we created and then when we visit that
route on line 11 we're actually picking
the ID off that that record that we
created and visiting it so it's the it's
a full control over the data there I
wanted to show you what filling in a
form looks like with an interactive so
we can change things as long as we want
here and the thing I kinda want to point
out here is this is interacting with a
date picker component which is actually
taken from our component library that's
shared between many like
ten or fifteen other UI applications
when we just import that interactor and
then just using our test suite we didn't
have to write interactions for how to
fill in and in a date picker for
selecting dates or anything like that
because that was already written for us
when we built the the component in our
component library so we fill in what
we're doing here is we're testing that
the application when we fill in a bunch
of bad data it'll give us client-side
errors so this is what the tests looked
like when they run as soon as I
interacted like interaction pops in and
we assert that those errors exist on the
page and the last one I wanted to give
as a more complicated example as
accessibility because I love
accessibility it's very near and dear to
my heart and this application we're
we're testing that our focus management
for the single page app actually still
works so when we travel our routes we're
making sure that it's focusing the
proper thing from each route transition
and making sure that it when we go from
one route on the transition back it's
selecting the the right item and an
infinite scrolling list so that's this
is what these tests look like so it's
running through all those navigating
routes going back and forth and making
sure that the focus is actually still
there
so I singled those tests out for you if
you want to see this application it's a
hundred percent open source so this is
where it lives its folio org folio
stands for the future of libraries is
open and we're building the holdings
application this app uses big tests
that's actually where big test was
developed it has over a thousand UI
tests and they all run about six minutes
on CI which are slower machines and your
local machine
we have 96% test coverage there we have
all kinds of tests there ranging from
all kinds of complexity so if you want
to dip your toes in and see what that
actually looks like go ahead and take a
look there are they're about like five
unit tests there and that's for testing
the Redux relationship merging so the
one question I get a lot is what about
graphic UL well with graph QL it's
actually even easier to use with big
tests and mock your data layer they have
helpers out there for creating a mock
server and
QL has a schema you just pass your
schema from your your epi and it can
come off all that data for you so you
just skip more lunch basically so
interactors are awesome and it seems
like they're a great pairing for testing
just components and you absolutely can
do that and we do do that like I
mentioned earlier so instead of
importing the setup app for testing
we're going to import the amount
component and a helper and we're just
going to mount a component here and I
wanted to point this one out so it's
from the same component here we're we're
passing a prop here called warning and
then on line 13 we're asserting that
that Prop exists with a feedback text
item on our interactor and if you look
at feedback text here on line 22 it's
actually using a CSS module so
interactors work with CSS modules -
those were built with in mind with them
in mind so you can just import those CSS
modules and use them as selectors so you
can get started by visiting big tests GS
do the CLI isn't quite ready yet but
give it like a week and we'll be there I
promise and big test is still in its
early days and we would love to have you
as a contributor if you're interested
I'm always open to pair and and help
people get there getting into it and get
their feet wet I love I love working
with anybody in the community so we
still have a lot of work to do this is
what our fully fleshed out emoji map
looks like so with zero config in mind
we want to build CLI that will handle
all the most mundane tasks for you you
don't so you can focus on writing tests
boilerplate snow fun we want to have
computers take care of that for you CLI
will also help and take care of
launching for you so you don't have to
use karma or test them but if you would
like you can still use those launchers
for your project also if you want the
last two items on this list are
longer-term goals we want to replace
mirage with something more modern that
uses serviceworkers and intercept
network requests so you have full access
to your network pane but for now mirage
does an amazing job for us and we don't
need to replace that so that's a
longer-term goal we have a lot of cool
ideas for what we can do with service
workers but
that's in the future and the last one
which is even further out maybe like mid
or early 2019 would be writing our own
runner so while you can still use it
with mocha or jasmine or jest or
whatever you want we want to write our
own runner that we can smartly split
your tests and paralyze them to make it
even faster like like I said we have
like 1,200 1,100 tests and that sweet
and they run in about six minutes we
think we can probably cut that down to
about two and we're looking at adding
other features like recording or honest
fail or screenshotting on fail but those
are further down the road I would like
to give a big thanks to will Lisbon he
basically wrote big tests himself I have
helped a little bit but this is all
mostly his work so I'd like to give big
thanks to him and I'd like you to give a
big thanks to front side for sponsoring
all the work on this for us to be able
to do it so thanks
[Applause]